I was afforded an opportunity that we
have under our props I'll turn the
prosecution's unit that in exchange for
the community service and his bond
forfeiture the case would be dropped she
lost her voice and her integrity all
right how does one get a spot in the
alternative prosecution's unit line all
right let me guess you're rich you're
privileged you're an actor and you share
the political beliefs of the state's
attorney who by the way did not formally
accuse herself recuse herself joining us
down delighted he's with us John knew
John of course from Berkeley and a
former Bush Justice Department what do
you think about this I mean Rahm Emanuel
suddenly is like put the brakes on oh no
no no President Trump go to opening
baseball cute first of all I think a lot
of Americans myself included are
outraged by this the fact that this guy
faked a hate crime look I'm a minority
you're a woman what if we were to be
attacked legitimately and now we're
going to be less believed by police and
prosecutors because of the example this
guy I think that's terrible I think a
lot of Americans realize something ought
to be done second this is why we have a
US Justice Department okay maybe he's
just spent a lot of time investigating
president Trump to no good effect but
now they actually exist to make sure
there is no corruption going on in state
government if you look at the details of
this case where mrs. Obama's chief of
staff calls the prosecutor Kim Fox and
then all of a sudden these masked
nations occur and then the case gets
dropped that is exactly what the Justice
Department is supposed to be involved in
is to make sure that there's no
corruption in state government so I hope
that President Trump is right and that
the FBI are starting an investigation to
look into this what's the potential
criminal exposure here both for Fox and
for the state's attorney office itself
so Fox could be potentially liable for
what's called mail and wire fraud of
depriving citizens of their honest
services which if she's convicted right
this is the standard law that's used to
go after corrupt state officials suppose
she got a bribe suppose she was promised
a fundraiser or who knows what other
kind of influence to drop this case the
maximum sentence is 20 years in prison
why do you think ramen
well took that turn I you know this is
takes a conspiratorial mindset I'm not
sure if I have the right one but Chicago
politics these are all people who are
interconnected they all worked in the
Obama administration or are working for
the Obamas now and for Chicago city
officials it doesn't it look like
there's some kind of pressure deal being
made to make this all go away
it's very also small at himself does he
have any exposure under federal criminal
law oh yeah his story's not over even
though the case under state law could be
dropped he can still be prosecuted under
federal law so he used the internet
again mail and wire fraud to engage in a
conspiracy to defraud namely the people
who's engaging in contract negotiations
with to defraud the people of Chicago
the city of Chicago Plus remember he did
this crazy thing before where he mailed
himself fake chemical weapons where he
mail himself a white powder claimed it's
anthrax tried to report that to the
police that's actually a federal crime
is to create a hoax about using chemical
I don't think anyone understands this
until you just said this I really don't
think anyone on television has explained
it that clearly but this is this is not
unserious stuff it's not just laugh
about it now this is really isn't this
funny this liberal actor kind of it has
to maybe pay a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars whoopty-doo I don't
have $3,000 and I don't think Michelle
Obama can call the Attorney General Bill
bar and get the charges dropped no I
don't think that's gonna happen John
it's always great seeing you thanks for
stopping by when you're in town